okay so the eight count
just some summary points it goes into
pairs they're kind of yin-yang pairs
um that's one point to remember so
on the first set one you step back
second set two you step forward
okay so that's a pair uh three are your
ten con
so you have your standard tan khan
and you have your ishido tank on three
and four
and then five you have this side step
one uh where you're moving towards
and six is the pair to five
is in essence you're going to do that
but to the side so you're moving away
okay so the guys over there
won't pop and then you repeat the form
guys over there who
[Music]
some things to remember in the entire
set
this is my opinion the footwork gets
redundant so
by the end here six
seven you're doing you gave me ten con
it's not really a new footwork
um and remember that the footwork is
really
goes back to just the basic yin yang
footwork
where i will either do a straight line
or a turn
and i do the same thing for both so my
knee will go
to the in phase which is knee to toes
that creates a forward angled ground
vector
which allows me to move the other foot
but it's also the same thing that allows
me to establish a single pivot point
which allows me to turn without being
double weighted
okay so in that sense
eight different steps
is kind of overkill okay
therefore when you're practicing this
set i recommend
maybe you just do the two pairs or maybe
even just
one okay because you're going to see
that we're doing
the amy tencon quite a bit now after
this all right so again going with
six completing the set to five
i'm going to step across the line
yield burn cut across the line
okay let's try six okay as i said the
form gets redundant so
in count one is that's when i stepped
back and cleared the line
so the same thing i had the weight shift
the rotation
so i go to the young phase knee to toes
that'll allow me the rotation and then i
step off the line that's count one
well that's all you're doing in count
six so but you precede it with the
me so young face step
shift and now you're going to do count
lines so i'm going to step back and
clear the line
so young face shift young face
rotate step by that's count the first
step and count
six so
when you do count six don't stay on the
line and come straight back here
and don't double pivot don't have your
line of gravity between so
shift shift
turn oh in and then repeat the flight
okay seven again the redundancy is here
that's why we're not going into detail
so seven is the db10 con put on the uh
12 6 line so i'm gonna go
do count two where i step forward
then turn and then i'm going to do
count one you need me tag five
um a turn to the right sword tip goes to
the right just like
counts five and six so yarn
in turn boom cut then
cut and then you do the same thing on
the other side so yawn
this is count one sword goes to the left
yawn turn step back home
and then you see boom
boom
okay let's go okay
eight eight the person is to my left
and i'm going to move over in the
footwork that you've
seen in ikyo okay so i'm gonna cross the
line
bring the left foot in and then the ski
turn cut cross the line
bring the left foot in cut
so again here
oh there's an interesting
part about hate because it reveals
something about
all the form so if you'll come out uh
it is it's more beneficial in forms
that you're not thinking in terms of
application
so uh for example
let's say my form has an inward
type movement so he does his stride
and i can use it as a block but
that same thing could be boom a smash
the same thing he goes again right it
could be a trap
or do it on the other side it could be a
break
and so when you're doing these
transitional moves these footy kabuti
he has a sword out which would be
normally there's some shoman cut
i i didn't do what people would
recognize as kitty
ash but you have your toshi moves in
there
and uh depending you have your different
cuts
too going the different different ways
and they can all be in the same mood
so when you do eight and he comes around
from the side prefer to keep
it in its way that it it's been going
which is in this
kind of generic kitty maneuver so
he's trying to cut on my head and it's
here
boom pop but obviously he goes
and you can do it this way uh
he goes you can do it that way uh
you can change the timing or come around
and you can do it at toshi as well
okay so we're going to leave it just the
standard uh
kitty edge you've been doing this whole
time that's good
so i'm here i'm bringing the tip around
boom
bring the tip around boom
but you know you could do any of those
different uh
twitty kabooties okay that's some some
final closing stuff
remember don't stack the weapon
so the tip goes up and then also
don't flex the wrist tip comes down
tip goes up tip goes down
secondly um
you don't you don't cut
your power isn't coming from
the fact that your body mass is moving
forward
so in other words still it's not that
i'm throwing myself
at him i can
use my inertia
but still connect it to a ground pop
when i hit so when i cut
it's not that i'm moving
so if you pay attention i end up cutting
on one leg
i always you're gonna always seek your
stance
boom when you cut
not cut out my legs
i do whatever the form is face
cut not
going forward base base
boom cut and the same thing goes when i
do the turning maneuvers
so uh ski when i turn
i'm not going to go forward again i'm
cutting on one leg so i turn
and i drop
a big component of a booty form
is tsubuti and a big component of
tsubuti
is conditioning full power where power
and aikido is called your power
cochlear power requires a ground
vectoring it's not
inertia power
so i'm always looking for that ground
vector when i cut
if you watch actual sword cutting
they'll have a base
the sword moves it's not that they're
throwing themselves at the target
there's no power in that it's a
different kind of power
we're not using that inertia power
so keep that in mind tip
up tip down and
get your ground vector as you're doing
all this kind of stuff
and and you're not in the air floating
floating all the time there's no point
to to putting if you're not doing
saburi okay try it again